[Musique]
et richard berry mes parents n'étaient
pas tout à fait pour je peux même dire
que c'était un peu contre et le fait que
je désirais très violemment faire du
théâtre peu à peu
j'ai réussi à les convaincre parce que
j'avais la foi c'est tout vous avez fait
quelques scènes dans le genre d'oreste
ah non ça s'est passé beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simplement toute façon si
c'était des scènes de ré c'était
certainement pas les fureurs vous allez
nous montrer une scène que vous avez
choisi vous avez travaillé les valet de
comédie mais finalement vous aimez mieux
le théâtre moderne comme tous les élèves
du conservatoire je crois et vous allez
nous passer une scène de vestiaire c'est
les quatre saisons quelle saison
avez-vous choisi puisque cette pièce
raconte les rapports d'un homme et une
femme à travers quatre saisons mais j'ai
choisi l'été vous n'avez pas un peu
charcuter là dedans et mélanger des
saisons si j'ai mis un petit peu
d'automne un petit peu divers mais enfin
du moment qu'on respecte le cheminement
de la pensée et que ça veut dire quelque
chose je crois pas que ce soit une
grande trahison
puis ça reste une scène le fait déjà de
jouer une scène c'est déjà un peu trahir
l'auteur alors tant qu'à faire
et bien leur famille del briçois vous
donner la réplique au pied levé puisque
ce n'était pas prévu mais heureusement
que nous l'avions alors c'est les quatre
saisons devait se faire ce qu'il fait
est difficile parce qu'il va prendre une
scène exactement dans le milieu et que
je lui donne quelques secondes pour se
mettre en forme
vous y êtes
il y a deux sortes d'amour et de sortes
de femmes
est ce que tu t'es jamais trouvés en
présence d'une femme très belle d'une
beauté à couper le souffle
est-ce que tu observée au plus tôt senti
les vague d'admiration et de mépris
qu'elle attire t remarqué à quel point
les gens autour d'elle éprouve le besoin
irrésistible de dire des choses sales
déplaisante pour montrer qu'ils ne sont
pas intimidés par sa beauté
c'était pareil avec mon rire et elle qui
n'avait aucun besoin de se mesurer avec
qui ou quoi que ce soit tant elle était
belle et intelligente elle a voulu se
mesurer avec sourire et pourquoi parce
qu il m'appartenait tu comprends elle ne
pouvait pas supporter qui ne met pas été
donné par aller alors elle s'est mise à
se mesurer à moi à défier tous qui
m'appartenaient à l'inventer des ennemis
ou il y en avait pas et voyez des
trahisons partout elle détruisait chaque
sourire est tous les moments de paix que
nous avions bâti et puis un jour j'étais
malade je lui écris de mon livre
l'injurier j'ai perdu toute mesure est
brusquement elle s'est calmée elle a
fait comme si c'était elle qui m'avait
donné ce rire est comme si elle seule
pouvait me rendre la santé sourire à
notre enfant me disait tel moi seul je
peux m'en occuper enfin toi tu en est
incapable
et puis ses paroles n'avaient plus de
sens elle disait je vois dieu en toi et
puis elle lancé du sial elle me
remercier de lui avoir donné la vie et
puis elle se vantait de m'avoir fait
elle applaudissaient et démolissait
aimait dévorer elle était folle folle
folle
personne n'a le droit de prendre son
rire un homme ou de nier la beauté d'une
femme elle mérite son malheur je suis
sincère moi je trouve ça pitoyable un
homme sincère c'est à ce que pensent la
plupart des femmes catherine
tu as de beaux cheveux
que c'est bon de pouvoir prendre les
cheveux d'une femme dans ses mains et de
pouvoir dire catherine tué à gauche veut
qu'à 38 beaux yeux et tes lèvres sont
belles dapo est belle tu me pardonnes
dire ça c'est parce que ça représente
pour un homme de pouvoir dire ces choses
à une fan tu sais qu'une femme a besoin
de les entendre dire mais tout c'est pas
la souffrance d'un homme qui n'a
personne à qui le dire ça tu sais pas je
ne toucherai pas
quand je te regarde je pourrais pleurer
alors ses larmes ne coulerait que pour
moi quand tu penseras elle dit moi
toutes les belles choses que tu te
rappelles
je me rappelle ma cruauté et je me
rappelle sa cruauté voilà je me rappelle
que nous n'avions pas peur de danser de
rire de jouer avec les enfants je me
rappelle que nous n'avions pas peur je
vous rappelle la mort de mon père je
tenais sa tête dans ses mains et je lui
disais respire aller n'abandonne pas et
ma mère à travers ses larmes qui disait
tu crois qu'il va écouter
elle souriait il nous semble tuant tous
les deux et je ne pouvais pas m'empêcher
de caresser ses yeux ses cheveux ses
joues voilà ce que je me rappelle
parce que les moments comme ceux-là me
font penser que le temps passe le temps
qui passe me fait penser à la tristesse
à la dévastation est à l'abandon
parce que je sais tout au fond de moi
que les beaux moments de la jeunesse ne
reviendront pas voilà catherine voilà ce
que je me rappelle voilà ce que je sais
[Musique]